the latest ps5 showcase revealed the
next gen console's release date and
price
plus some new game announcements let's
talk about everything you need to know
first and foremost the ps5 will be
launching on november 12th
in the us canada mexico japan
australia new zealand and south korea
europe and the rest of the world can get
their hands on it on november 19th
the standard ps5 will cost you 500 us
dollars
while the all digital edition which has
no disk drive will be 400 bucks
check gamespot for more pricing info for
your region so what games can you
actually play on launch day
you can jump into assassin's creed
valhalla demon souls devil may cry 5
special edition
and spider-man miles morales there are
also a ton of games coming to ps5
at or around launch day and that list is
a lot longer
that list includes deep breath black ops
cold war
bug snacks godfall immortals phoenix
rising marvel's avengers ratchet and
clank rift apart
and a bunch more you can see the
complete list on gamespot
and take note a lot of these games are
gonna be sold for 70 bucks a pop
instead of the 60 we're used to paying
for games right now
you'll also be able to play backwards
compatible ps4 games
sony previously said that the 100 most
popular ps4 games will be playable on
day one
with more to come what's more the
showcase revealed the playstation plus
collection
ps plus subscribers can download and
play a bunch of ps4 favorites on ps5 on
day one
including god of war persona 5 until
dawn
days gone and more that seems like a
great way to play any physical ps4 games
you already own if you decide to go with
the diskless ps5 model
now if you're concerned about having
enough storage to keep and play all
these games
good news the ps5 comes with an 825 gig
solid-state drive what's more you can
increase your storage with third-party
drives if you wish
that said sony hasn't given its
recommendations for what ssds will work
best with the ps5 architecture
so you should wait before committing to
one keep an eye on gamespot for any news
on that front
and stay tuned as we keep covering the
ps5 with handy videos like this
and our weekly show generation next i
know i'm excited to hear more about
final fantasy 16
and that god of war sequel
you